ROBERT-JAN HUIJSMAN:
In this talk
I would like to talk to
you first about Firebase
and what Firebase is,
what it can do for you
what it can do for your apps.
I'll show you a few examples.
I'll talk you through
the whole thing.
But then I will also introduce
you to some of my friends
here from NU.NL, NUsport.
They have built an actual
app on all the stuff
that I will be
talking to you about,
and they're excited to
tell you about their app.
But first, let me
tell you a little bit
about what a Firebase is.
Firebase is basically your
front door to Google's Cloud
if you build apps, and apps, in
the broadest sense of the word,
be it mobile apps or a web app.
If you are building
something with a small team,
if you're building something
with mobile users or web users,
you can use Firebase as your
front door to Google's Cloud.
What would that bring you?
Well, Firebase has
a suite of products
that help you with
app development,
and it works on all platforms.
It works on iOS and
Android, clearly--
these are the dominant mobile
platforms-- as well as the web,
as well as for game developers,
C++, Unity, the whole shebang.
So on all of those
platforms, we can give you
a number of tools that will
help you develop your app.
And I'll talk through a
number of the highlights,
but the key point of this slide
is quite how many there are.
There turn out to be
many issues that you need
to solve when you build an app.
And we hope to attack at least
all of the hard ones for you
so that you can spend more
time doing the fun code,
and we do the
nasty part for you.
So let's dive into a
few of the features
that help you develop your app.
We have a few
features as well that
help you grow your
usage, et cetera,
once you have a successful app.
But let's first dive into
how you develop an app.
The first feature, and the one
that many, many people start
with when they start
to use Firebase,
is our realtime database.
And this is-- it's
a NoSQL database.
It's a database that can store--
imagine it as an
object in the cloud,
and your applications
can connect
to parts of that object,
listen to changes.
It does a whole bunch
of stuff for you,
for example, the
synchronization between devices.
Let's say that you
have a bunch of devices
that are all interested in
the same set of your data.
For example, I, right now, am
carrying two phones, as well as
a laptop and a tablet,
in my bag over there.
I might have them
with me all the time.
If I press a button
on my phone, I
would like to see the
change on my laptop as well.
The realtime database
does all of that for you.
This is the realtime--
the realtime part
of it is that when
I press that button on
my phone, it immediately
changes on all of my
other devices as well.
It takes care of that
synchronization for me.
The other part that
is cool is that it
does reconciliation of things
like poor connectivity.
So let's say that my tablet
that is making a change
is currently offline because
the Wi-Fi here is oversubscribed
with thousands of people,
and it doesn't currently
have a connection.
It'll buffer those updates,
and when my tablet next
comes online again, it'll
sync all of those changes
to all my other devices.
And I didn't have to
write a line of code
to make that happen.
So compare this to a model where
you would write your own API.
You would have to
deal with the fact
that your tablet was offline.
You would have to
deal with the fact
that maybe other
changes have happened
in the meantime, et
cetera, et cetera.
All of that done for you.
Authentication is
the next feature
that I think many
people look at.
Authentication does user
sign in, either with username
and password or with a
phone, with a phone number,
with SMS verification, or with
an OAuth provider, something
like Google or Facebook, or
your own existing auth system
if you already have it, as well
as anonymous, and a whole bunch
more.
So this is a problem that
every app developer has,
approximately.
You need to sign in your users.
You need to know who they are.
Firebase Auth does it for
you with an out-of-the-box UI
in about two lines of code.
So the next time you're
writing a log in page, don't.
Hosting will let
you host a website.
It'll give you a
free SSL certificate.
It'll connect to
your existing domain.
We have storage which lets you
put large files in the cloud.
And there's a whole bunch
more of these features that
help you do things that
many app developers need
and many app developers have
had to reinvent in the past.
No more.
Now, let's say that you have an
existing app, and you like it,
and your users like it.
And they use it, but you'd
like there to be more users,
or you'd like your users
to be more engaged.
Hopefully, this is
a problem you will
get to once you have
an app that works.
And so we have a
number of features
that help you grow your app.
Firebase Cloud
Messaging helps you
do things like send
messages to your users.
Things like push
notifications, et cetera,
are something that many of us
have had to build in the past.
Firebase Cloud Messaging
helps you do that.
Remote configuration helps
you do things like hmm,
I have built a game, and level
3 is a little bit too hard,
and I'm losing too many
gamers at that level.
Let me tweak down
the difficulty level
of that level a little bit.
Done.
And what Remote
Configuration does
is it synchronizes that,
basically, parameter
change to all of your users
to, to the million users that
have installed your
app, without them
having to update their app.
Great.
Analytics.
If any of you have ever used
Google Analytics on the web,
you have thought
to yourself, wow,
what would I do without it?
Because it tells you
so much about what
your users are doing
on the website.
It tells you so much about
where they came from.
Now you can all of that
in your app as well.
And I do promise you, if you
have an app that uses this,
your next app will also use
it because you will never
want to do without it again.
And the nice thing
about analytics
is that it is a free product.
By the way, all of the
products I talk about
are free to use for, like,
hobby sort of things.
You can experiment with
it today if you want,
no credit card needed, even.
Analytics is free forever.
So you can use it for--
I don't know-- if you're
NU.NL, for example.
So we have many,
many cool features
that help you build apps.
This is just a few of them.
But how do you put
them all together?
How do you meld them
all into one app
and respond to what happens in
all of these different systems
as things happen?
The answer to that--
oh, sorry.
I can give a few examples
where this is a problem.
For example, if I were using
a traditional backend, not
Firebase, all of these
things would be hard.
For example, let's
say that I want
to send a notification
to my users
when they have received
a new chat message.
I need to be running a backend.
That backend has to be able
to receive messages from users
all across the globe.
It has to be able to persist
those messages somewhere,
and then have some
sort of integration
with, for example,
Firebase Cloud Messaging,
to send out the message to the
user who received the message.
Or another example,
resizing images
once a user uploads a photo
to Firebase Cloud Storage.
Let's take that example and
dive into it a little bit more.
So I have an app, and it wants
to upload a picture to storage
and resize it.
In the past, what
you would do is
you would talk to
your custom backend,
and it would say, aha,
let me place the original
in one place on storage, and
then let me resize the image
and put it in a different
place on storage.
Ta-da, I'm done.
Great.
This seems like it would work.
And it seems effortless, right?
Until you realize
that, yes, this
gives you the
thumbnail, the resizing.
It does not give you
resumable uploads
of your original picture.
It does not give you resumable
downloads of either the result
or the original picture.
It does not give you
end user authentication,
whether they were permitted
to write that picture
in the first place.
It does not give
you a pay-as-you-go,
sort of cloudy model
that we've come to love,
because you have to run that
physical virtual machine
or even a piece of
actual hardware.
So it's not a
pay-as-you-go model.
And it certainly
isn't global scale,
unless you do a lot of work to
do this all across the globe.
And then, again, you
will pay even more.
So using Firebase instead
of that traditional backend,
all of these things
become a whole lot easier
thanks to Cloud Functions.
This is the newest item
in our lineup, the newest
product in our develop
tier of products.
And it makes all of
these things easier.
So let's take another
look at the example
of the photo being uploaded.
The way Functions
works is something
happens, and you'd like to
do something in response.
So for example, a photo is
uploaded to Cloud Storage,
and I would like to
create the thumbnail.
Using Cloud Functions,
that is really easy,
because this photo uploaded
to Cloud Storage is an event.
You receive that event.
As a Cloud Function,
you trigger off that.
You do something, for example,
creating the thumbnail.
To give a little bit more of a
complicated example, let's dive
into the realm of
machine learning, which
I know lots of you
have heard about today,
before, things like I
upload a sound file.
I might say, [DUTCH].
The Cloud Speech API
understands that this
is Dutch that I just spoke,
transcribes it, and puts that
into a database.
So we used a Cloud Function to
realize that a sound file had
been uploaded to the cloud, to
push that to the Cloud Speech
API, which does
machine learning,
to recognize that speech, and
we wrote it back to Firebase.
But now, now that I've
written this back to Firebase,
Firebase has an event,
which is something
was written to the database.
And we can trigger
off of that again.
And we can say, OK, let me
translate the word [DUTCH]
into English, for example,
and get the result "cat,"
and write that back
into the database.
So we built a pipeline,
a data pipeline of sorts,
with machine learning, et
cetera, built in, with--
well, this turns out to be
about 10ish lines of code.
The example that I gave
here actually exists.
You can go to saythat.io/source,
and you can see on GitHub
the code that we've
written for that.
And you can clone
it, play with it.
It works.
So you're wondering
what sort of events
can I trigger Cloud
Functions off of?
Well, first and foremost,
we have HTTP endpoints.
This is a pretty standard, I'd
say, model that we're used to.
Somebody comes and hits
your website, basically.
You want to respond to that.
This generates dynamic content.
It's great for generating
dynamic websites.
But since this is in
the Firebase world,
we also work with the
Firebase realtime database.
We work with Cloud Pub/Sub,
with authentication--
this is the user sign in system
that I just talked about.
So for example, a
new user signs up.
You would like to hear about it.
Great.
Cloud storage for Firebase,
as well as Google Analytics
for Firebase-- this
is the tool that
tells you what your users
are doing in the app.
So for example, you might
get something like a "Oh, my.
Oh, dear, there was a crash."
And this user is one of the
most valuable users that I have.
Let me send them a coupon
code just to say sorry.
Great, that engages your user.
It keeps the high
value user in your app,
even though they've just
had a bad experience.
Firebase Hosting lets
you host your web pages.
Now those web pages can
be dynamically generated
using Functions.
And we have more of
these coming up soon.
So here's an example of
some actual code for a Cloud
Function.
And I should pause
for a moment and say,
you've probably heard
about Cloud Functions
before me just standing here
from other people standing
here.
Cloud Functions exists in the
wider cloud world as well.
In the Firebase world,
the app development world,
we've added a few tricks to
make things easier for you.
So for example, in this
case, we're using Node.js.
And this Node.js imports
an SDK that we've
written for you to make
writing functions as easy as we
could make it.
So our top line says,
I will import this SDK
that we've written.
And then we export a function.
And we are going to
call it Hello world--
gee, how creative--
and we say functions.
This is an HTTP function.
And I would like you to
respond to a request.
You get the request
and the response
object when the actual
request happens.
This is much like a
Node.js express app,
if you've ever used
any of these before.
And you can send the
result that you would like.
Now the cool thing
about this is to get
this running in
the cloud, all you
do is type on your command
line, Firebase Deploy.
If I go back one step,
you see that in this line,
we had all of the
information we needed
to create a function that
actually runs in the cloud.
And what we do when you
run Firebase Deploy here,
we read your code
for you, we see
what functions you would
like to run in the cloud,
we run them for you.
It is that easy.
There's no flags.
It is, for me at least,
the simplest solution
that I know of running code
in a globally scalable way.
Here's a slightly more
complicated example.
The thing I wanted
to call out here
is that the system
works the same
when you have not an HTTPS
endpoint, but a database event
that you want to listen to.
So for example, you
say Functions Database
when there is a write to
the following reference.
On that write, give me an event
and trigger a bunch of code.
And this particular
code is an example
where we take the time
stamp of the write,
and we write it to the
database so that we can always
persist a time stamp with
every write that happens.
So this is the old
world that we were
in before we were
using Firebase, where
our mobile apps had
to talk to an API that
had to talk to a backend,
and the backend, maybe,
had some custom code
running in it, et cetera.
In the new world, you
take your custom code,
you upload it to the
cloud, to Firebase,
and it glues the whole
application together.
So by using the various
Firebase features,
we address all the
various pain points
you get during app
development, and we just
get from zero to app much,
much faster than we did before.
And by using Functions, all
of those different features
now feel like one platform.
So that's my brief
introduction to what Firebase
is, what you might use it for,
and how you use Functions,
which we're all
very excited about.
But you've probably heard a lot
of Googlers talk about, yeah,
I'm so excited about the thing
that I work on, which is true.
But for you, I
think it's much more
interesting to hear about an
actual use case, something
from the real world, people
who've actually used Firebase
to great effect.
So I would like to invite
up my friends from NUsport,
and they're going to tell
you about a real app using
Firebase.
[APPLAUSE]
ISTVAN FONAY: Yes, thanks
for a cool presentation, RJ.
So we are from NUsport.
As you might know,
that's part of NU.NL.
And we would like
to show you today
how we used Firebase to
create the fastest sport
app of the Netherlands.
My name is Istvan, and
my colleague is Johnny.
He's one of our awesome
backend developers at NU.NL.
So a brief introduction
about NUsport.
NUsport is sport at its best.
And what we aim to do is to
provide realtime, instantaneous
news to our users about
their favorite sport events,
even if there are more
of them at the same time.
So some facts and figures.
NUsport has around
300,000 downloads,
1.3 million weekly page views.
And we are also quite happy
that our users are engaged.
So during matches we
have, for example, polls.
And we have usually
around 10,000 poll votes
on these votes,
which is really nice.
And we also have
1,500 blogs weekly
in the app, which might
sound weird at the moment.
But as soon as you will see
how the NUsport app looks,
then you will see
what I mean by that.
So a bit spoiled this already,
but the goal of the NUsport
app is to be the fastest
sport app of the Netherlands,
in short.
And there's an
interesting thing I
would like to mention about the
development of the NUsport app.
So we started to create the
new NUsport app last year,
before the Champions League.
So we wanted to be done
for the Champions League.
And I don't know how is it
usually at your organization,
but at ours, it can
happen sometimes
that we have quite
challenging deadlines.
And it was also the
case with NUsport.
So we had two months to
develop two apps from scratch,
and also create the real time
backend, and the clients,
and everything we needed for it.
So we had a few
options to do that.
One of the options was
to go to the market
and buy a complete third party
package, software package,
with the realtime backend,
with clients, everything.
But that cost quite
some money, and we
like to spare money
where it's possible.
So that was not an option.
The other option was to
create the realtime backend
and the clients ourself.
But back then, we didn't have
too much experience with that.
And due to the
deadline, it would
have been quite challenging with
experimenting and everything,
so we also didn't
want to do that.
So our best option was
to choose Firebase.
So we did that.
And there are also some other
reasons why we chose Firebase.
So I wanted to
mention three here.
It's fast, it scales with
you, and it's cost efficient.
So it's not only
fast in the sense
that-- you will
soon see in the demo
when we push
something to the app,
it shows instantaneously
in realtime.
But it's also fast in
the sense that it's
really easy to implement for
iOS and for Android as well.
And you can implement it
really easily and fast.
It also scales with you, which
is really important for us.
Because as you might imagine,
the nature of the NUsport app
is a bit cyclical.
So for example,
on a busy Sunday,
when the [INAUDIBLE] stop
is rocking it in Formula 1,
we have an IX and Feyenoord
game, and maybe even
cycling event going on, then
we have much more users than
on a boring Tuesday
morning at 9:00
AM when there's
nothing happening.
So it's very important for
us that yeah, our systems
can scale with us.
Firebase just does that.
And that leads to my next month.
It's also quite cost efficient.
Because as Robert-Jan mentioned,
it's a pay-as-you-go model.
So obviously, on
Sundays when we have
more users and higher loads, and
you use more data, we pay more.
But on Tuesdays, when it's
boring, then we pay less.
And that also keeps our
managers happy [INAUDIBLE]..
So how are we actually
using Firebase?
I would like to mention
three features here
which are interesting.
The realtime database.
So if you look at
the app, then you
see that we have some blogs.
And this is actually a timeline.
And as the new sport
events come in,
then they always end
up on the top right.
So it's a bit like a
Twitterish timeline.
And we use different blogs
to show these newsbeats
to our users.
So we have pictures, videos,
Instagram, Twitter blogs,
all type of things.
And this is all done with
the help of Firebase.
We also have ball blogs.
And also, we have
the scoreboard,
which you can see
in the top there,
which obviously, you
have to update nonstop
because the match
is going on, so you
need to show the minutes
of the game and the goals.
And that's done in
realtime, and the user
doesn't need to do anything.
So he doesn't need to swipe
down or press something,
but it's just being
pushed to his device.
And the end user, obviously,
has the newest information.
So that's pretty cool.
We also use Cloud Messaging.
So obviously, we use
push notifications.
And we use it to
personalize the experience
of the users in the app.
So users can sign up
for different sports,
like football,
Formula 1 cycling,
and they get the most
important news delivered
in the form of push messages.
Another interesting
thing is Remote Config.
We use this to optimize a bit
the user experience in the app.
So when you open the
app, we can set--
remotely, on the
fly, without needing
to submit a new app to the
app store, or whatever--
we can set how many blogs
appear for you on the screen.
So in this way, we can optimize
the loading speed of the app.
So these are things
that we are doing now.
But we also have some
additional plans.
The first plan to implement
Firebase for NU.NL.
And this we already
achieved, actually.
So if you can imagine, NU.NL
app is a totally different scale
than a NUsport app, so
NU.NL is the biggest news
site of the Netherlands.
We have millions and millions
of users every month.
So then we use Firebase
for breaking news events.
So when something really
big happens, and you
come to our website or apps--
so we use it on iOS,
Android, and web.
When you come to
the website, then
if you click on the article
about the breaking news event,
then you will see the
same blog structure
as you can see in
the NUsport app.
So we use Firebase there as
well, and it works really well.
And it also scales really good
in doing these breaking news
events, when we have
hundreds of thousands
of people coming to
our apps and website.
Firebase Analytics.
You can do really cool things
with Firebase Analytics,
and also in combination with
other Firebase products.
So for example, with
Cloud Messaging--
in the NUsport app,
for example, we
could create user groups,
user segments on the fly.
So if we see that people
are clicking on the IX
and Feyenoord blogs, then
we can create a segment,
or send a push
notification, only
to those people who click on
these blogs with something
personal, and with a
promotion, or whatsoever.
So you can do really
cool things with that.
And Cloud Functions.
Back then, when we started
to develop the NUsport App,
Cloud Functions was
not available yet.
So we didn't use
it at the start.
But now since it's
available, we see
some really cool opportunities
how we can implement it.
And that's something
what Johnny will tell you
more about with the demo.
JOHNNY MIJNHOUT: Yes.
Thank you, Istvan.
Hi, everybody.
I'll give you a small
demo of the NUsport app.
If you can just
unlock the phone.
ISTVAN FONAY: Yes.
JOHNNY MIJNHOUT: Thank you.
Yes, it works.
So you can see our
content management system
in the first column.
This is where we add the blogs.
We have several types of blogs.
I will demo the text
blog, but as you can see,
if I click here, it has a
dropdown list with some types.
We integrate with
Facebook, Instagram.
We can add balls, et cetera.
The middle column is
the Firebase console,
where you can see
our database, which
is a pretty simple structure.
But before you
get through there,
when you're used to using
relational database,
that's kind of tricky.
But we managed it,
and it's working.
And the last column
is the actual app.
And you can see a scoreboard
blog, and an image blog,
and at the bottom
there is a text blog.
And you can see them also here
inside our content management
system.
And I will add a new
text blog, something
like "I am Johnny at NUsport.
Color is red.
Catch me outside.
How about that?"
So I store it, and
you'll see it's
added to the Firebase
database and instantly
being added inside the app.
And what's cool is we don't
have the load of the user.
So if we have one user, or
if we have a million users,
everyone connects to
the Firebase database.
So if a very simple machine
running our upend server,
and we don't have to scale
up when more users are added.
So I can, of course,
also edit the blog.
Just a typing mistake
I can see here.
And some here.
So when I store it, you'll
see an update coming here,
and also the app is also
immediately updated.
Maybe you also noticed
the scoreboard blog--
I'm back to here--
is still sitting on top.
But I added a new blog,
and it appeared below it.
And we added some functionality
we call painting blogs.
As you can see
here, the scoreboard
has a tiny pane added.
And when you add blogs
or content to Firebase,
you can also add
a hidden priority
field, which is just a number.
And it's ordered from 0 to--
yeah, up, running,
so it's 0 to 9.
And we created something.
The not been blogs
are just a time stamp
of when they are created,
but are negative.
So we have new ones on top.
And the pin blogs are
hard numbers, which
is a very low negative number.
So we can pin them, always on
top, which about 100 years.
From then, I won't be here,
so nobody will blame me.
So that's about it, I think.
I can also delete
it, and you can
see it deleting from Firebase.
And leaving from here.
And it's always this fast.
So it doesn't matter
if 1 million users are
connected to it, or one user,
it just works instantly.
So back to the presentation.
And these are some learnings
we had during development
and when we were done.
We're never done,
but somewhat done.
One was the bandwidth usage.
You are charged for the
bandwidth you are using.
We have a pay-as-you-go--
how do you say it?
ISTVAN FONAY: Model.
JOHNNY MIJNHOUT: --model.
And it turned out that we were
using about 1 terabyte of data
per month.
And there was
something in our data
structure in the beginning.
We were looking to
too much updates.
So if you don't subscribe
to the right endpoint
inside your database,
then you get
a lot of updates where
users are not watching.
So you need to think before
you leap into this structure.
And it's also, at one
point, a NoSQL database,
which you already mentioned.
We're used to using
relational databases.
And now we had to flatten our
structure and keep all simple.
So that's something, yeah.
It's not very hard, but you need
to think about it beforehand.
And the final thing
is the sharding.
As each one said,
Firebase scales with you,
but it scales to
a certain level.
And we didn't know before,
but there is a level.
And there's a maximum of
100,000 concurrent users
per Firebase project/database.
And since we're also
using this for NU.NL
when a news event happens,
it's pushed to all our clients,
and we have about more
than a million clients.
So if they all open the
app at the same time,
they will go to
the same timeline.
And then we will have
more than 100,000 users.
So we talked to Google
on how to fix that,
and they said, well, most users
are using sharding for this.
And what it is--
we just have our main database,
and we just clone it 20 times.
So we create 20
Firebase databases
which all contain the same data.
And we're updating
it from our backend,
so every time we
update a blog, we
send it to all the 20 shards.
And the clients just
randomly connect
to one of those 20 shards.
And now we have 20 times
100,000 concurrent connection
possibilities.
So I think we can
manage with that.
But we'll see.
Yeah, I think that's it.
I will give the word back to RJ.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT-JAN HUIJSMAN:
Thank you guys so much.
It's always just exciting to
see people using our stuff,
but like NU.NL using our stuff
is especially exciting to me,
personally, coming
from the Netherlands.
Thank you guys so much.
ISTVAN FONAY: Thanks.
ROBERT-JAN HUIJSMAN:
Thank you guys so much.
If you would like
to talk to us later,
we'll be hanging around for
a bit, and we'd love to chat.
Thank you, and enjoy
the rest of the evening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]